it's the first weekend of May 2019 so
time for another monthly update video
I'm going to talk about what we've got
coming up this month of May and what
went on during April I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and these are three pretty big things
this time around so without any further
ado here they are big thing number one
I'll be releasing the second of the
self-directed study in philosophy videos
we'll do a video premiere on that on the
18th of May and this one is going to be
about Aristotle so if you like the Plato
one we've got an Aristotle one coming up
as well the second big thing is coming
up much sooner if you're here in the
Greater Milwaukee area I'm giving a
lecture in the philosophers in the midst
of history quarterly series this one is
on Thomas Aquinas his times all the sort
of intellectual and political
developments that were surrounding what
was was happening and what made him such
an important figure and the third thing
is a bit more far off it's actually
about October we will be doing a stoic
on X Midwest here in Milwaukee we don't
yet have the venue lined up but we think
that it's probably going to be at the
end of stoical week so that that
Saturday second Saturday in October
there'll be more information about that
coming out in the future so those are
the three big things what went on in the
month of April it was quite a busy month
we started with talk on Lewis Carroll in
the worlds of speculative fiction series
we talked about his world building what
there is of it and some philosophical
themes in his works particularly the
Alice in Wonderland works but also some
of his other stuff as well I had quite a
few online events you know my usual AMA
session the
half-hour Haegele Q&A and discussion
sessions what else we of course had the
video release of the self-directed study
studying play-doh video I talked about
that a little bit at the start and we're
gonna have an Aristotle one coming up
this month it was an extraordinarily
busy month for teaching as many of you
know I am currently teaching five
face-to-face undergraduate classes and
you know April is the month where
everything is coming to a close so you
know projects and exams and you know
last-minute panic emails and people
actually coming to office hours all of
that sort of thing going on I took out a
few more new clients as well and I got
quite a bit of writing done and editing
work for Stoicism today and for my
author blog or xst and noetic a you can
see links to them below as well and I've
been engaging in class building because
I'm teaching online summer courses for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design an
existentialism class that begins oh less
than two weeks from now and an online
business ethics class from Marquette
University that begins in early July I
did some video work actually quite a bit
of video working out all of which has
been released at this point shot core
concept videos Dostoevsky Sartre and
Nietzsche some of which I released I
continued releasing the Descartes videos
that I had created on the meditations
earlier this semester I did get one book
review video done on a Long's recent
I've actually got to hear how to how to
die which is his translations from
Epictetus I actually got an email from
long saying that he liked the the video
which is quite nice of course I did the
Plato
you know self-directed study video and
that's kicking off that series which I'm
going to finally get on track and create
more of those and there's videos from
the events as well particularly the
Carroll and me
online am a session I also released one
podcast episode I need to get you know
cracking on these but I just haven't had
the time to crank them out these are my
Sadler's lectures where I take the video
lectures that I already have turn them
into mp3s clean up the sound take out
all the omens and ahhs and you nose and
things like that and then make them
available for people to listen to and
down download worldwide so that's what
went on in April we have a pretty packed
events calendar for the month of May it
kicks off on Tuesday the 7th at the
Frank Weinberg library and Mequon so if
you're local here in the Milwaukee area
or you want to drive up from Chicago or
down from the Fox cities that is the the
library will be hosting the next of the
quarterly series philosophers in the
midst of history this time we are
focusing on Thomas Aquinas big heavy
hitter in medieval philosophy and still
influential today on the 9th which is a
Thursday 7:00 p.m. Brookfield Public
Library we continue with session 36 of
our worlds of speculative fiction series
and this time we're focusing on Tanith
Lee's gorgeous novels in her flat earth
series wonderful stuff I'm rereading it
now you know getting ready and it's a
really great stuff to dig into on the
11th online event at 12 p.m. Central
Time make sure you check your time zones
I'll be holding my AMA that is asking me
anything session so if you've got
questions for me and you want to put
them to me and hopefully get an answer
if yes early enough you'll get an answer
if you have too late in the session
maybe not go ahead and join me on
YouTube live for that then on the 14th
which is a Tuesday at 5 p.m. we'll be
having our public free online half-hour
Haegele Q&A and discussion session you
don't need to be a patreon supporter to
to show up to that and interact with me
in real-time but it is of course under
written by my patreon supporters of the
project so that's you know if you're
interested in Hegel German idealism
philosophy more generally show up and
we'll chat on the 18th at 12 p.m.
that's another online event so Central
Time I will be releasing my as yet not
yet shot but will be by that time how to
do self directed study with Aristotle
video and I will be answering questions
in real time at the premiere in the chat
window to the side so if you show up and
you've got some questions about that
I'll be happy to interact with you as we
watch the video for the first time that
same day 3 p.m. another online event
this one just for patreon supporters
it's my philosophy chat which I do once
a month video conferencing with some of
my supporters it's a perk that that they
get so if you want to join in and you
want to become a patreon supporter right
and then we have to face-to-face events
here in the Milwaukee area both are
members of larger organizations that
have local chapters here in Milwaukee on
the 22nd we at 6:00 p.m. at the Central
Milwaukee library will be having our MKE
Sophia Sophia is the Society of
philosophers in America we'll be having
our our chapter meeting discussing the
nature of public philosophy doing some
meet-and-greet talking about the events
that we've got coming up later in the
fall and then finally on the thirtieth
6:00 p.m. we have our our you know MKE
stoic fellowship meeting and this time
we're actually looking at some stoic
exercises talking about how we might
apply them in our life and we'll also be
discussing irelia PSA's meditations book
2 so that's going to be a really fun
meeting that is at the Shorewood Public
Library and you can find all of these
events on my Facebook page my facebook
author page or in the
reason IO Events Calendar if you go to
the website now still wrapping up
classes MATC doesn't finish up until the
end of May but my ad that's the
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
where I'm teaching two classes this
semester
they are done I am in the middle of
grading and grades are due Tuesday
coming up this this next week Marquette
is almost done they just have to finish
their final papers hand in any
outstanding work and take their final
exams online and then I have to grade
their stuff and those grades are due of
course the next week Tuesday so I've got
a lot of grading that I'm doing and
fielding of course questions from
panicked students who may be a little
bit behind in their work I'm taking on
some some new clients after the semester
is done for my tutorial sessions
philosophical counseling maybe even
doing some more consulting work here in
the summer and I'm doing a lot of online
course development some of that is for
academic courses I mentioned the my ad
class on existentialism and I mentioned
the Marquette business ethics class but
I'm also building out new classes in the
reason IO Academy so stay tuned for
announcements about that which you'll
see on my author blog or xst know when
to K I'll do videos about them so if
you're interested in taking online
courses with me not for credit but for
personal enrichment and getting access
to the kinds of stuff that I do then you
want to pay attention to my study with
Sadler or teachable Academy a lot of
video work ahead so I may get to
shooting some more videos on Rene
Descartes I'm not quite sure if I'll get
to those or not but what is definitely
lined up for me our core concept videos
on Rainer Maria Rilke is letters to a
young poet Gabrielle Marcel's on the
ontological mystery Simone de Beauvoir
second sex only selections of that of
course and Alberto moves mythos if
assists and what else
I going to do there was somebody else in
there who who I I have to shoot videos
on for this existentialism class but you
can see those rolling out I've got the
aristotle self-directed study video
coming up will premier that there should
be some event videos from from the
various talks that i'm giving or online
events I'm gonna do some more book
review videos now that I have a little
bit more spare time and maybe even do
some Q&A stuff and this is the month
where I'm finally gonna get to shooting
some more Hegel footage once I get my
head clear of all this grading stuff I
can start shooting half an hour Hegel
videos again I know people are looking
forward to things from the morality
section I'd like to bring that to a
close this summer and so we got to get
cracking on that in in May I'm also
going to be converting more of my
lecture videos into podcasts so I've got
some more Epictetus material lined up
for you and I'll also be doing some
stuff on the Nietzsche material that I
just recently shot and some on Aristotle
as well some on the materials that I I
shot for my students this semester so
that's a lot going on in May but I think
we should be able to get through it
provided you know I don't get sick or
you know anything else goes wrong we I
should be able to get done with that
that sort of production schedule so I
hope to see you in some of the online or
face-to-face events if you like the work
that I do consider becoming a patreon
supporter that helps me have more free
time to do the sort of online content
production that I do and have a great
month and I'll see you some of you here
in the ether
you